speaking of people who are a disgrace is
the view had Billy Porter on and Billy
Porter I've never we'd never quite
speaking I guess it's also maybe a
historic mystery that will have to be
unraveled but
um
how did this guy ever become a thing I I
it's not exactly clear other than the
fact that he's black and flamboyantly
homosexual and so I guess that explains
it but that's all he's really got going
for him and uh he was on The View
talking about drag queens and offering
his defense of it let's watch
when you were here in July of 2022 yes
we talked about how Florida Governor uh
DeSantis uh had just filed a complaint
against a bar called the r house that
holds drag shows okay eight months later
things have only escalated as we talk
about it you know it's constant um
aggravation with this what do you make
of the fact that we're still talking
about this and that um it's happening in
other states too not just Florida yeah
it's there's this war yeah against trans
people which is an lgbtq plus people and
people who are othered and Cabaret and
Cabaret people it's a circle of life
yeah you know why are they doing it for
power yeah everything is about power and
you could always trace it back to the
money you say that all the time yeah you
know it's follow the money follow the
power power at any cost it's very
hypocritical you know the the leading
cause of death in children are guns yeah
yeah they're guns yeah
I know it's the morning and I'm not
supposed to be screaming but they're
guns yeah
not drag queen no leave us alone
you know
it's a distraction it's a distraction on
purpose we don't know what to pay we
don't know what to pay attention to you
know our justice system is convoluted
it's hard to understand on purpose let's
be clear about that it's on purpose you
know it was like when we were talking
when we were talking about Roe v Wade
that the word codified came up I was
like what is
50 years what's
happening yeah you know subpoenas
if any one of us is subpoenaed we and if
we don't go we end up in jail what's
happening that's the question we all
have when we look at this guy
um so a couple things here
first of all I like how Cabaret people
that that's been added into the list
that's been added into the list of uh
there's a war on Cabaret people
is that is that now a cap is that a
category of identity that we're so we
would put that in the LGBT uh alphabet
soup
Cabaret people
he says the leading cause of death among
children is um our guns
and that's not even close to true
not even close
okay the guns don't even
um they are a fraction of what is the
actual leading cause of death among
children that would be abortion
that's hundreds of thousands of children
killed every year through abortion
so not even close
guns are a distant distant second place
I mean the whole thing is a is uh
obviously a ridiculous straw man red
herring I mean uh no no one is being
killed by drag queens no one ever said
that they are
okay but so is that the standard is
anything is okay for children as long as
it doesn't directly kill them
so whatever it is as long as they are
killed by it on the spot it's okay
well these people they they cannot
defend any of their positions because
their positions are horrifying insane
nonsense and they know and they can't
defend it and so the astronomy is all
they have
they have to constantly argue against
um points that no one is making
Jon Stewart did the same thing it was a
big gotcha moment he was interviewing
someone a couple weeks ago
drag queens aren't killing anyone yeah
who said they are that's not the point
you that's not what we're saying
we are
um proposing this this radical idea that
there can be things that are bad for
kids even if they aren't killed by it
okay there's there's like things that
are good for children and then there are
things that kill children
but there's a lot of room in between
those two things
it's not as though well as long as it's
not here and killing them then it's
automatically good
do we really need to explain this to you
clowns do you need this explained to you
we always come back to the same question
of are you as stupid and crazy as you
are pretending to be
you just always assume that you're not
but maybe maybe my assumption was wrong
and then we hear that it's about the
money and power this is all about money
and power
what money is there in in telling drag
queens that they can't strip for little
kids
okay when we tell you that you're not
allowed to uh cross-dress and perform
sexually for children you think we make
money on that
we make money on you not sexually
um you know sexually harassing children
which is what
you know which which is what dancing in
drag for child that's what it is
um so you think
you think we might how do we monetize
that how do we monetize you not doing
that
power like what additional power yeah I
mean if we if we stop you from
sexualizing children then and we're able
to successfully stop you then that is
exerting power I suppose but this is not
this is power that we would never want
to have to exert because it shouldn't
come up in the first place
but no there's no money in it
the money is always is on that side
and that's the case for all these things
if you notice that there's a the
financial incentive is on the other side
okay
um
there's millions and millions and
millions of dollars at stake in the
gender transition industry
that is a
multi-multi-multi-million dollar
industry
uh and you've got pharmaceutical
companies wrapped up into it medical
industry hospitals clinics doctors
nurses therapists counselors
psychologists psychiatrists all these
people okay and that's not even to
mention the professional activists and
the advocacy groups or the all these
people uh not even mentioning that but
but if you bring all that together
you've got tons of money
that they're making on this
um and if this stuff is outlawed and if
we're outlawing the transiting of kids
it's not like the money goes to us now
it's not like there's millions of
dollars go to us it's just they're not
getting spent they go away no one makes
them
okay there is not in fact a
multi-million dollar industry of
stopping kids from being castrated that
industry doesn't exist
same thing with abortion as he mentioned
where's all the big money there
abortion is a billion dollar industry
okay a billion dollar industry is
abortion
because they charge money
goes in pays someone you oftentimes a
man this is female empowerment I'm gonna
pay a man to kill my child
because I'm an empowered woman
lots of money on that
it's also self-serving
okay people defend the right to an
abortion for their own convenience and
for their own lifestyle and they'll tell
you that it's it's they're very open
about it
pro-livers on the other hand we don't
make any money off of this
okay we don't make money off of you not
getting an abortion
and we also don't benefit from it
directly
we don't directly benefit from you not
killing your child
we're speaking up for the child we don't
we don't benefit from that
um
I mean the most you get yeah there are
there are crisis pregnancy centers out
there Pregnancy Resource Centers I'll
tell you something the people that are
in that business they're not wealthy
okay they're not making it anywhere
close to what the abortion abortionists
are making
but even that if you want to if that's
the big Financial incentive so yeah
getting that really profitable business
of paying a of working at a Pregnancy
Resource Center you know real profitable
a lot of money to be made there I mean
we're talking hundreds of dollars
but even that little pittance I mean the
the as we fight against abortion
and uh if as we as we succeed
in mitigating abortions
um
then I mean it's kind of like the goal
of a pro-lifer is to make yourself and
to make this movement
unnecessary
to make it irrelevant that's our goal
while on the other side they are
clinging to relevance and profit margins
and all the rest of it and that's the
again that's the case down the line on
nearly all these issues that'll do it
for this portion of the shows and move
over to the members block you become a
member today use code walls to check out
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]